احييكم مشاهدينا ونحن مستمرون في هذه
التغطيه التي نخصصها دائما للاوضاع
الجاريه في السودان حيث تدخل هذه
الاشتباكات يومها السادس لكن قبل ذلك ظهرت
بعض البوادر الايجابيه سيام الهدوء النسبي
في مناطق الاشتباكات حيث اعلنت الاليه
الثلاثيه التزام طرفي الصراع بهذه الهدنه
وان كانت جزئيه ومؤقته فيما لم يعلن عن
فتح اي ممرات او جهود ميدانيه لحل ازمه
المدنيين الذين يعانون من نقص مياه الشرب
والمواد الغذائيه وانقطاع الكهرباء
بانتظار ما سيحدث خلال الساعات المقبله من
هذه الهدنه
[موسيقى]
ومشاهدينا هناك ايضا اخبار عاجله ترد على
شاشه العربيه بيان للجيش المصري يتحدث
ويقول بانهم لا يزالون ينسقون مع الاطراف
السودانيه لتامين عوده كل العناصر المصريه
للبلاد اذا بياننا للجيش المصري يتحدث فيه
عن تنسيق مع الاطراف السودانيه لتامين
عوده كل العناصر المصريه
للبلاد اذا مشاهدينا هذه الاشتباكات التي
حصلت منذ خمسه ايام ونحن ندخل اليوم
السادس هي ما زالت مستمره كانت حتى دخول
هذه الهدنه حيز التنفيذ حتى الان يبدو بان
هناك اجواء ايجابيه بانه هناك التزام بهذه
الهدنه على كل حال لنعرف المزيد ينضم الى
من الخرطوم يوسف عزت مستشار سياسي لنائب
رئيس مجلس السياده وقائد قوات الدعم
السريع اهلا بك سيد يوسف هل يمكن ان
تطلعنا على الوضع الان وبالنسبه للهدنه هل
التزام مئه بالمئه من قبلكم
نعم نحن نلتزم بالهدنه مع الاحتفاظ بحق
الرد اذا هجمت اي من ارتكازاتنا او
المناطق التي نسيطر عليها نحن التزمنا
بالهدنه والان ننفذ عمليا هذه الهدنه نحن
نسيطر على مناطق واسعه جدا في العاصمه
القوميه بمدنها ثلاثه فنحن ننظر الى
الهدنه على اساس انه هدنه انسانيه يجب ان
يستفيد منها المواطن لان المواطن خلال
الخمس ايام الماضيه عانى كثيرا
الى المستشفيات حتى يخرج بعض الطلاب الذين
ما زالوا يقبعون في المدارس والجامعات
نعم نعم نعم نحن الان فتحنا كوبري شبات
لمرور كل
العابدين من بحري الى ام درمان الى بحري
فتحنا كوبري شرق النيل المنشيه فتحنا
كوبري
الحديد كل هذه الكباري التي يمكن ان يمر
منها المواطنون الى اي مكان يريدون الذهاب
اليه يمرون باتتكازاتنا يجدون منها كل
العنايه اللازمه هنالك بعض الاصوات
المتقطعه للرصاص من قوه منسحبه من قوه غير
ملتزمه بالهدنه ولكن في المناطق التي
نسيطر عليها قادرين على ضبط هذا وغادرين
على تيسير المواطن هنالك مشكله بسيطه في
بحري وفي درمان في الخرطوم وهي اغلاق كل
البقالات والصيدليات نحن نريد عبر هذا
المداخله اريد ان اناشد كل اصحاب البقالات
واصحاب الصيدليات ال ان ان يفتحوا استثمار
لهذه الهدنه لصالح المواطنين نحن مستعدين
حمايتهم وحمايه امتلاكاتهم اثناء هذه
الهدنه لان المواطنين لا يجدون يهمون على
وجوههم عبر الشوارع لا يجدون اي مكان
يشترون منه منه اي
مواد غذائيه او ادويه يحتاجون اليها هذه
هي المشكله التي تواجهنا الان في المدن
الثلاث عبرك وناشد كل اصحاب البقالات لا
يخافوا الذاتوا المناطق التي نسيطر عليها
ويفتحوا عدلاتهم بشكل عاجل
لتقديم خدماتهم للمواطنين استاذ يوسف ما
هي المناطق التي ما زلتم تسيطرون عليها
نحن نسيطر على بحري بشكل شكلي كامل مسيطر
على الخرطوم على القياده العامه نسيطر على
مطار الخرطوم نسيطر على امتداد شارع
المطار الى نهايه الازهري نسيطر على شارع
مدني الى كوبري سوبا مسيطر على النيل بشكل
شبهي كامل نسيطر في درمان على الاذاعه
والتلفزيون مسيطر على مداخل الكباري شبات
منظم الكباري تحطنا هذه كلها المناطق تقع
تحت السيطره فترمان ايضا في صالحه في كل
المناطق لدينا قوه كبيره ترتكز هناك
ولدينا انتشار واثق في العاصمه
الاشتباكات اين تتركز استاذ يوسف
يستغل الجيش الهدنه لتحريك
لمهاجمه محيط القياده لمحاوله الدخول بعد
عمليات فاشله طيله اليوم هاجم الجيش في
الصباح بالمطبقيه الصغيره القوات انا داخل
القياده العامه قام بانزال جوي فاشل للاسف
تم قتل جميع الذين تم انزالهم داخل
القياده العامه
وهي ارواحها نتمنى ان لا
نفقدها ولكن عمليه متهوره تم تحريك رتلي
من الدبابات
لاستعاده الغاز العامه وكلها حرقه هذه
العمليه تجري الام ايضا هنالك محاولات
للقياده العامه
اسمح لي ان نسال عن موضوع الجنود المصريين
كانت الاخبار يعني منذ تقريبا ساعتين
تحدثت بانه بعض الجنود وصلوا الى مصر وان
هناك تنسيق مع السودان ليصل كل الجنود الى
مصر هل يمكن ان تطلعنا على الجنود الذين
كانوا في قاعده مروي وما هو مصيرها نعم
حين سيطره قوات الدعم السريعه على مروي
على قاعده مرويه
تسلمت او سلم لها جنود مصريين هم ليسوا
اسرى لانهم لم يكونوا محاربين ليسوا
رحائل
اتصلت القناه الموجوده بيننا وبين
القياده المصريه اكدنا للقياده المصريه
انهم تحت حمايتنا ومسؤوليتنا
ونضمن سلامتهم الى حين يتوفر المناخ
المناسب لتسليمهم الى قيادتهم بعد ان قررت
قياده الدعم السريع خلال قاعده مروي
العسكريه
واستجاب القوه للخرطوم لتعزيز الحرب
الدائره هنا
اخذت القوه مع المصريين وعدم تركهم لاننا
لا نظم سلامتهم بالنسبه للحرب
وتم تسليمهم الى الى قيادتهم وتم فتح
المطار الذي يسيطر عليه وهبط الطائره
واخذتهم الى بلادهم سالمين سالمين هذه هذه
الحديث كان
بكى تنسيق مع الجيش ايضا لوصول هؤلاء
الجنود الى الى مصر يعني بيان الجيش تحدث
بانه كانت تنسيق مع الجيش لوصول الجنود
الى مصر
لا تنسيق ليس مع الجيش لانه هم نحن الذين
نضمن للقياده المصريه سلامه هؤلاء جنودهم
معنا اكثر من خمسه ايام موجودين معانا تمت
معاملتهم معامله كريمه ايضا الجيش لا
يمتلك سلطه فتح المطار ولكنه قال بانه
ينسق مع الاطراف السودانيه من هي هذه
الاطراف انتم لانه لانه وصول طائره
واقلاعها في ظل حرب يتطلب التنسيق مع كافه
الاطراف حتى لا تتعرض الطائره لاي نيران
حتى لا يفسر بانها دعم لطرف من الاطراف
يعني هذا الاطراف هي انتم يعني كان هناك
تنسيق بينكم وبين الجيش في هذه العمليه
نحن لم ننسق مع الجيش في هذه العمليه
بالكامل السلطات المصريه هي التي نستغرت
وضمنت جانب الجيش ان لا يرتدي على الطائر
هذه السلطات المصريه هي التي قامت بذلك
التنسيق نحن ليس لديها اي تنسيق مع الجيش
ولا نحتاج لذلك لان المطار في يدنا
والجنود في يدنا
وخرج المراقبه ليعمل فيه يعني يستطيع
الاستجابه يستطيع ازاله الطائره بسلام
واغلاقها بسلام وتم تامين كل العمليه من
قبل ان لم يكن هنالك اي تدخل الجيش في
العمليه ولكن السلطات المصريه قد تكون
نفسها مع الجيش
لعدم الاعتداء على مايره واوصل اطلاق
النار اي اطلاق نار في اثناء هبوط الطائره
واقلاعه في المناطق المجاوره
للمطار هذا هذه مساله نحن ليست فيها نحن
تنسيقنا بالكامل مع مع المصريين
بالنسبه ايضا لهذه الهدنه هي من المفترض
ان تكون لمده 24 ساعه هل هذه الهدنه في
كافه الاقاليم حيث هناك اشتباكات بينكم
وبين الجيش ام فقط في الخرطوم
نحن ننظر للهدنه في كافه الاقاليم لكن في
الاغاني التي تدور فيها المعارك لا توجد
ازمه انسانيه بالحجم الذي توجد في الخرطوم
في الخرطوم خلال الخمسه ايام عاشت معارك
عنيفه هنالك انقطاع للخدمات هنالك مرضى في
المستشفيات نحن اليوم نحاول يعني مرضى
حالات طارئه جدا برضه في الاعلان مكثفه
بمستشفى الاكثر من 20 مريض انقطع عنه
الاكسجين لا ادري حتى الان هم على قيد
الحياه املاح حاولنا جهدنا ان نفتح المراه
المعارك لم نستطيع العبور الى مستشفى
وانقطع الاتصال بيننا وبين الشخص المناسب
لهذه العمليه هنالك حالات طارئه حالات
تحتاج الى هدنه تحتاج هذه الهدنه هدنه
انسانيه بحته تحتاج الى فتح للمواطنين
المواطنين ولكن مياه هنالك الشحف
في الاكل هناك اغلاق شيء فيتام للمتاجر
هذه الهدنه هذا هو هدفها
ايضا اريد لموضوع الجنود المصريين يعني
حسب الاخبار التي وردت منذ ساعتين بان
هناك قسم وصل الى مصر هل تؤكد لنا هذا
الموضوع وماذا عن الدفعه الثانيه
الجنود المصريين نحن الذين سلموا لنا هم
الذين كانوا داخل القاعده لا ادري اذا كان
هنالك جنود اخرين ولكن هؤلاء الذين كانوا
في القاعده هل كلهم وصلوا الى مصر هل يمكن
ان تؤكد لنا ذلك نحن سلمناهم جميعا لا
ندري هل تم
تقسيمهم او احتفظت المصريه هنا بجزء منهم
ام لا لكن نحن سلمنا الطرف المصري كل
المصريين الذين بيدنا واخلينا كامله من من
هذا الامر
استاذ يوسف يعني الان انتم ليس لديكم اي
جندي مصري لا ليس لدينا ليس بطرف كلهم
كلهم سلمتوهم
لاي جهه سلمتوهم
للسلطات المصريه الموجوده في الخرطوم
طب من اي مطار تم نقل هؤلاء الجنود الى
مصر
وسط القذايف ووسط الحرب تمت عمليه
تسليمهم في مكان عامل تم نقلهم للمطار
بترتيبات معينه هذه عمليه فيها جانب عسكري
فيها
ترتيباتنا
السلطات المصريه فهذه عمليه
اليوم الذي يمكن نتحدث عنها كيف تمت ومتى
الساعه كم ومن تسلم
بان كل الجنود المصريين اصبحوا في مصر
الذين كانوا موجودين في قاعده مروي
انا لا اقول كل الموجودين في قائده مرو كل
الموجودين بيد الدعم السريع هنالك مساكن
للمصريين
للمصريين انا لا ادري هل هي اخرين ما
زالوا في مروي هل تم نقل الاخرين كلهم الى
الخرطوم نحن نقلناها المجموعه التي بيدنا
نقلناها مع القوات التي تحركت من الخرطوم
وتم تسليمهم مع الدعم السريع يمكن القول
بانه تم تسليمهم بالكامل
نعم
اشكرك استاذ يوسف عزت
المستشار السياسي لنائب رئيس مجلس سياده
وقائد قوات الدعم السريع على المشاركه
معنا وعلى هذه
التفاصيل التي يعني خصيت فيها العربيه
شكرا لك
حرب الازقه والشوارع معديه وقد تتسرب شيئا
فشيئا لحاره مجاوره واخرى لها طالما ان
الجنرالين سقطا بمحظور الاقتتال الداخلي
فخ اوقع بدول محيطه منذ سنوات انها شخص
اقتصادها وافقر شعوبها
السودان لاحقه بالركب ولم يفوته القطار
دوله شلها غياب المركزيه السياسيه
والعسكريه كما جيرانها ليبيا وسوريا
ولبنان حيث يفترض انها دول مستقله تتمتع
بالسياده وحق تقرير المصير اي دول ديجيوري
وفق القانون الدولي لكنها وجدت نفسها على
الجانب الاخر من القائمه دول مسلوبه
القرار ومهمشه بحكم الواقع او ديفاكتو
هذه الفوضى الداخليه مرميه على حافه
التوسع بحكم موقع السودان الجيو السياسي
بالغ الاهميه فالوضع السوداني يهدد بنشر
الفوضى في دول مجاوره وعيسى في بعضها فساد
بالاصل ارتريا واثيوبيا من الشرق تشاد
وليبيا من الغرب وصولا الى مصر من الجهه
الشماليه فمن شان اي اضطراب في السودان ان
يزعزع امنها القومي ويضر بحصصها المائيه
مع سعي اثيوبيا لتعبئه سد النهضه السودان
يطل كذلك على البحر الاحمر الذي يربط اهم
ممرين بحريين هما باب المندب وقناه السويس
ما يزيد مغريات الدوله الذهبيه الكثيره في
عيون دول كبرى بينها روسيا وتركيا فحلم
القاعده البحريه هناك تتشاركه الدولتان
حرب الجنرلين تمتلك الخلطه الناجحه
والسريعه للحرب الاهليه للاشتباكات طويله
الامد وتوزعها على مساحات واسعه وامكانيه
انزلاق الحركات المسلحه الاخرى الى المشهد
اما الحل السياسي المامول فبايد ليست
متوفره حاليا بل ممدوده الى اوكرانيا
وتايوان حل لن يكون مغيرا عن سابقه
الخجوله قبل اندلاع حرب اللا منتصر اي
خساره الطرفين وانتقال القياده لطرف ثالث
اطلاق النار الذي دخل حيز التنفيذ اول امس
شهدت شوارع المنطقه نوعا من الهدوء حيث
خرج بعض السكان للشوارع في مختار البعض
الاخر التجمع لتناول الافطار
من الخرطوم ينضم اليه الان مراسل العربيه
سالم الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك معنا هل يمكن
القول بان هذه الهدنه اليوم هي افضل وهي
اكثر التزاما فيها من الهدنه التي اعلن
عنها بالامس
نعم قد تكون هي الافضل منذ انطلاق هذه
مبادره كذلك هي الافضل حتى الان لكن مع
ذلك تتخللها العديد من الاختراقات فيما
يتعلق باطلاق النار المتقطع في مدن مختلفه
من ولايه الخرطوم
لكن هناك تحديات تواجه هذه الهدنه في
مساله
سراج العالقين وكان من اخرهم الذي ورد
الينا ان هناك عالقونا الان في
احد شوارع
في عماره التي تقع في تقاطع شارع القصر
والجمهوريه هؤلاء العالمون هم 29 معظمهم
من الاجانب بشارع قريب من القصر الجمهوري
ومن بينهم اطفال وصاحبي هؤلاء العالقون
نفذ عنهم الماء وهواتفهم اغلقت لنفاذ
الكهرباء وهم موجودون في تلك المنطقه
لا يتمكنون من الخروج لان القوات منتشره
ما زالت في هذه المناطق خاصه هذه المناطق
التي هي تعتبر قريبه جدا من الاماكن التي
يكون فيها الاشتباك دائما
فانتشار هذه القوات بهذا الحجم الهائل
يصعب جدا معه الخروج ايضا نضيف الى ذلك
انه الان لم يقف اطلاق النار تماما هناك
اطلاق لنيران متفرقه بين الفين والاخرى
لكن انا قلت في بدايه هذه المداخله انها
هي الافضل مقارنه مع الماده السابقه لكن
فيها اغلاق نهار فيها مدافع ثقيله وخفيفه
ومتفاوته الازمنه ومتفاوته كذلك في
المناطق التي يتم فيها اطلاق هذه النيران
طيب سالم بالنسبه للدفاع المدني للصليب
الاحمر هل اصبح بامكانه ان يتنقل ان يتحرك
خلال هذه الهدنه
لم يصدر الهلال الاحمر حتى الان اي بيان
ولا حتى
وزاره الصحه عن عن تحركاتهم او انهم اخذوا
ضمانا من احدى الجهتين في التحرك او حتى
قاموا بالتنسيق من اجل الضمان هذه الممرات
وهذا ما تحتاجه هذه الهدنه الهدنه تحتاج
الى ان يكون هنالك ضمان الطرفين الى ان
يكون هنالك طرق معينه لاتفاق حولها من
الجانبين ويتم اخلاء هذه الطرق من المظاهر
العسكريه وسحب هذه القوات من هذه الطرق
لاجل ان يمر فيها تمر فيها هذه المساعدات
وتمر فيها ممكن سيارات الاسعاف كذلك وتكون
ممرا امنا ليصل بها حتى الكوادر الطبيه
كذلك للمستشفيات وصول المواد الغذائيه
كذلك كل احتياجات المواطنين ان تمر عبر
هذا الامر ايضا ينتظر هذه الهدنه كذلك
موضوع ايضا غايه الخطوره وهو موضوع الجثث
التي هي ملقاه في الشوارع حتى الان في
اكثر من شارع وتاتينا الشكاوى كثيرا من
مواطنين يحصلون في المناطق القريبه من
وجود هذه الجسد انه يجب ان تبدا هذه حمله
يعني يعني حمل هذه القصص من هذه المناطق
وبعد ذلك يتم ارسالها الى المشارح او يسير
بعد ذلك التصرف معها من قبل الصليب الاحمر
وهو المختص في هذا الجانب
اشكرك حتى الان سالم ابقى معي ولكن دعنا
نذهب الى عبد الله عطيه سكرتير نقابه
الاطباء في السودان استاذ عبد الله اهلا
بك معنا هل يمكن ان توجز لنا وضع
المستشفيات في هذا اليوم السادس لهذه
الاشتباكات التي تقع بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله تعالى وبركاته
شكرا للاستضافه في البدء خالص التعازي
لجماهير الشعب السوداني وامنيات الصحه
والعافيه
للجرحى
والمصابين وايضا عودا حميدا لكل المفقودين
نعم كما ذكرتي الوضع في السودان الصحي
والانساني في تدهور مستمر خروج عدد من
المستشفيات خارج الخدمه
رصدنا حتى الان 41 مستشفى رئيسي كنا نعود
عليهم كثيرا عدد الوفيات يزداد في كل لحظه
وحين تجاوز اكثر من 180 منذ صبيحه اليوم
وازداد خلال خلال اليوم
هذا الرقم فقط يعني وسط المدنيين كذلك عدد
الجرحى في الزياده العمليات العمليات
العسكريه مستمره يعني نسمع بوقت اطلاق
النار ولا نراه على ارض الواقع عدد من
حالات النزوح خارج الولايات الخرطوم
وتعرض بعضهم لمضايقات وصفهم وصف هؤلاء
الناجحين عدد من كبار السن والمرضى
والاطفال ايضا وصلتنا نداءات كثيره من
مرضى داخل المنازل تنعدم لديهم الادويه
الضروريه وهي وبعضهم هو يعاني من امراض
مزمنه خطيره
عدد من المستشفيات تعمل الان بطاقه بسيطه
جدا مهدده للاغلاق في اي لحظه
هل يمكن ان تصف لنا وضع المستشفيات
بالنسبه للكهرباء بالنسبه للمياه للمعدات
الطبيه للكادر الطبيه اذا هناك من اعداد
كافيه داخل هذه المستشفيات
جزء من المستشفيات تعاليم الانقطاع تاملي
التيار الكهربائي بدا يعني بدا مخزون
الجازولين للمولدات الكهرباء ينفذ ايضا
كذلك المعدات والمعينات الطبيه هي ايضا
النافذه بعض المعينات وصلت من خيرين ولكن
كانت لا تكفي ايضا الطواقم الطبيه لا
تستطيع النزول الى هذه المستشفيات لذلك
نحن نطالب بنزول هذه او عفوا نطالب بوقف
الاطلاق النار فوري وتمكين الكوادر الطبيه
وحمايتها للوصول الى المستشفيات ايضا
نطالب بحمايه المستشفيات وعدم وعدم
اتخاذها مطيه او منصه لاطلاق النار بين
الطرفين
هناك يعني قصف للمستشفيات يعني كم مستشفى
تم قصفها او طالها هذا القصف
اكثر من 13 مستشفى تم قصفها وتم مهاجمتها
والاعتداد والاعتداء عليها
حمايه هذه المستشفيات وهذه المرافق
الخدميه ومنصوف عليه في المواثيق
والقوانين الدوليه لذلك نحن نطالب طرفي
الصراع في السودان باحترام القوانين
الدوليه طب كنقابه هل تتمكن من
الاتصال بطرفي النزاع
لتنشدهم او لتسمعهم هذه المناشدات لابعاد
المؤسسات الصحيه كالمستشفيات والكادر
الطبي عن هذا النزاع
لا ليس لدينا اي تواصل مباشر معهم ولكني
بالتاكيد تصلهم نحن ارسلنا خطاب رسمي
لمجلس الامن الدولي
وطالبناه بالضغط على طرفيه الصراع لايقاف
هذه الحرب وايضا تامين مسارات امنه
ليعلم طرفي الصراع في السودان ان القانون
الدولي حتى بين الطرفي الصلاه عندما تكون
دولتين هنالك تامين لمسارات امنه لذلك نحن
نطالب بهذه المسارات الامنه تامين مسار
للاسعاف وعدم تعرضها لاي مهاجمه كما حدث
في الخرطوم وايضا في جنوب دارفور الوضع
ايضا هنالك مرضى عالقين في بعض من
المستشفيات انقطاع الاكسجين في بعض من
المستشفيات هي واحده من من الاسباب
الكثيره التي سوف تؤذن او تؤدي الى
انهيار النظام الصحي الذي نراه انه على
حافه الانهيار تماما نعم شكرا لك طاهر
المعتصم
عفوا عبد الله عطيه سكرتير نقابه الاطباء
في السودان ساذهب الان الى طاهر المعتصم
الكاتب الصحفي من الخرطوم استاذ طاهر اهلا
بك معنا كيف يمكن ان تصف لنا هذه الهدنه
هل تشعرون بان هناك التزام فيها
مساء الخير عليك سيدتي وعلى المشاهدين
الكرام
الهدنه رغم بداها قبل ساعات قليله هناك
هدوء نسبي ولكن هناك انتهاكات واضحه هناك
مناطق سمع فيها
ذوي اطلاق الرصاص في منطقه الخرطوم بحري
تحديدا في شارع السيد علي المرغني وفي
مناطق اخرى ايضا هناك
انتهاكات للهدنه من قبل قوات موجوده على
الارض من الاطراف
تمنع مرور المدنيين بثلاثه والمرضى وغيرهم
الخرطوم اليوم شهدت حاله نزوحي الاكبر في
تاريخها في تقديره نحو ولايات اخرى اكثر
امنا
داخل الخرطوم النزوح هو داخلي استاذ طاهر
ان يتوجهون الى خارج الخرطوم
يتوجهون خارج الخرطوم الى ولايات اخرى
تحديد الرصدنا الطريق الى ولايه الجزيره
وهي ولايه الشرق الخرطوم متاخمه على
الخرطوم تماما
رصدنا اعداد كبيره من
المواطنين المدنيين ينبحون نحو
عاصمه ولايه الجزيره مدني وبالتاكيد هناك
مناطق اخرى ولكن بصعوبه التحرك لم نستطيع
رضها
على كل حال نحن نتابع على شاشه العربيه
هذه الصور من الخرطوم هذه الصور الخاصه
بقناه العربيه حيث يبدو بان هناك التزام
بالهدنه حتى الان على الرغم من ان هناك
يعني من وقت لاخر تصنع رشقات ناريه في
الخرطوم لا ادري اذا كان هناك من صوت
طبيعي من الممكن ان ايضا نسمع
الصوت الطبيعي لنتاكد من انه ليس هناك من
اي قصف في هذه الاثناء
نعم انا هنا استطيع ان اؤكد لك ليس هناك
قطف في هذه الاسماء انا في مدينه الخرطوم
بحري
ليس هناك قصر حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن هناك
اخبار عاجله حسب صحيفه السوداني الجيش يصد
هجوما اثيوبيا امس على الفشقه الصغرى
الحدوديه اذا حسب صحيفه السوداني الجيش
يصد هجوما اثيوبيا امس على الفشقه الصغرى
الحدوديه
والهجوم كان معززا بالدبابات وايضا
المدرعات
وكان هناك حشود ايضا من
القوات الاثيوبيه اذا حسب صحيفه السوداني
الجيش يصد هجوما اثيوبيا امس على الفشقه
الصغرى الحدوديه ايضا تصل المعلومات بانه
كان هناك تحشيد للمشاه الاثيوبيه بالاضافه
الى
[موسيقى]
تحديدا منطقه الفشخه
بحصد بعض المعلومات التي توثرت ان الجيش
السوداني سحبت اعداد من هذه القوات
السودانيه الموجوده هناك لحمايه الحدود
لم نستطيع ان نتاكد من هذه المعلومه ولكن
لصعوبه التواصل مع المصادر مؤكد ربما اغرى
هذا الامر
جانب من الفصائل الاثيوبيه ربما تحديدا
الامهره لانهم هم المسيطرين على هذه
المنطقه المتاخمه للحدود السودانيه
ربما في الساعات القادمه يتضح الامر اذ
كان هذا الوضع
بيتبعا للحكومه الاثيوبيه ام هم الامهره
كل اعلم ان هناك
ظروف تعيشها الجراثيوبيه ولكن هذا الامر
بالخطوب من الخطوره بما كان ويصنع تحولا
كبيرا في المشهد السوداني الان كما قلت
يعني البعض ايضا يتخوف من انه هذا
الاشتباك ان يكون لديه امتدادات داخليه او
خارجيه من خلال هذا الخبر يبدو بان هذه
التخوفات في مكانها وانما الامتدادات
الداخليه الى اي حد استظاهره من الممكن ان
يتحول هذا الاشتباك الى مناطق اخرى الى
ولايات اكبر ويصعب السيطره عليها
دعينا نقول ان موقع السودان الجغرافي يحيط
به عدد من الدول الان اسمع ذوي اطلاقه
اسلحه ثقيله
لو لو
طاهر تسمع هذه
هذه الاطلاقات
في الخرطوم بحري
نحن نسمع معك ايضا دعونا نستمع الى الصوت
الطبيعي لو سمحتوا
اذا نسمع اطلاق نيران في الخرطوم بحري
يؤكد لنا استاذ طاهر المعتصم ضيفنا الكاتب
الصحفي وهو المتواجد في الخرطوم نحن
نسمعها على الشاشه من خلال الصوره التي
تصلنا
طبعا هذه الصور خاصه بالعربيه من خلال هذه
الصوره نستمع الى اطلاق النيران ويؤكد لنا
استثرا المعتصم ضيفنا الان بانه ايضا هو
يستمع الى هذه
الاصوات وهي في الخرطوم بحري اعود اليك
استس طاهر
نعم
انطلاق هذه الاصوات قبل قليل يؤكد ان هناك
فروقات دعينا نقول ان موضع السودان
الجغرافي
العديد من الدول المتاخمه له تمر بظروف
سياسيه صعبه جدا مثل ليبيا وغيرها هذا
الامر الان اذا ما ورد في صحيفه السودان
وهي صحيفه لديها موسوغيه كبيره
لدى الصحفيين في السودان مؤكدا انه يفتح
جبهه جديده
تنوع بعبئ كبير على الجيش السوداني اذ انه
يواجه في الخرطوم بمعركه صعبه انا اعتقد
ان الجيش السوداني في وضع معقد اذ ان
الجيش السوداني بما عرف عنه لديه التزام
بالمواسيخ الدوليه القانون الدولي ومن
اهدافه حمايه المدنيين بالتالي هذا الامر
يشكل عليه داخل
انه يخوض حرب مدن مع قوات الدعم السريع
التي هي بطبيعتها قوات تقوم على التحرك
بسرعه
وليس كالجيش وليس لديها التزام واضح على
حسب علمنا ومراقبتنا الماضيه بالقانون
الدولي او بحمايه المدنيين
بالتالي لو فتحت جبهه الفشقه مؤكده ان هذا
الامر من الخطوره بما كان وسيغير في
المشهد الجاري يعني كيف يمكن ان يغيره ما
طبيعه هذا التغيير استاهل ما المقصود به
طبيعه هذا التغيير ان
المواطنين السودانيين سيقفون ضد اي تدخل
خارجي
ستوحد الجبهه الداخليه بصوره كبيره هناك
انقسام يمكن ان نلاحظه الان ولكن دخول طرف
خارجي سيوحد الجبهات داخليه تجاه اي تعدي
او هجوم من الجاره اثيوبيا بحسب ما اوردتي
على صحيفه السوداني بالتالي سيجعل الجيش
السوداني امام عبء ايضا كبير
لحمايه الحدود الشرقيه وهي حدود واسعه جدا
وايضا لديه حرب المدن التي يخوضها والتي
فرضت عليه لان الدعم السريع هو من اختار
مكان المعركه اختارها ان تبقى معي
لنذهب ونتابع هذه او هذا الفيديو لصور
من تحليقها مقاتلات تابعه للجيش السوداني
ومن ثم اعود لمتابعه
تحليل هذا الوضع او قراءه الوضع الان في
السودان معك ومع ضيوفنا
[موسيقى]
الحمد لله على
الساعه السابعه ولا الساعه الثامنه
في شارع الستين
بالغرب من مبنى البشاري الاساس والديكور
سابقا شركه السوبر ماركت عماره سنتر كان
الوظائف طائشه يعني ما كانت موجهه بحدف
معين لانه شارع 60 ما كان فيه اي نوع من
الاشتباك من اول يوم لحد اليوم ما كان فيه
لحد اللحظه من الاشتباك كانت طايشه كانت
بتقع داخل الاحياء
60 وكان بتوع الاسره متجهه من الطائف الى
شندي
اليسرى بتتكون من اب وام
واه الاثنين وبنته وزوجته ابنه
الوظيفه
الرئيس
اخترق السياره وماتوا الابن وزوجه الابن
في الحال
اذا مشاهدينا الاشتباكات مستمره في
السودان في عده مواقع بين الجيش والدعم
السريع الاشتباكات تحولت حقيقه الى حرب
مدن مفتوحه وفيما الحسم هو رهن بالايام
المقبله يواصل الطرفان عملياتهما الجيش
اعلن استعاده مطار مروي وايضا سلاح
المهندسين ومنشات حول مقر القياده العامه
للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم حيث ما تزال
قوات الدعم السريع موجوده هناك قوات حميتي
فشلت بتحييد القواعد الجويه والمطارات
الاساسيه في البلاد خلافا لخطتها الاساسيه
فبعد اقتحامها لمطار مروي شمالي السودان
واعلانها السيطره عليه عاد الاخير لقبضه
الجيش السوداني واقتصرت مكاسبها جويا على
قاعده جبل اولياء جنوبي العاصمه اضافه الى
مطاري الفاشر وايضا مطار سبيره الدولي
غربا فشل قوات الد سريع بالسيطره على كافه
القواعد الجويه مكن الجيش من استخدام
مقاتلاته لاستهداف تمركزات وسيارات الدعم
السريع في العاصمه وهي اليات غير مدرعه
وهي سهله التدمير كما ايضا مهد استخدام
سلاح الجو الطريق امام الجيش للسيطره على
مقرات رئيسيه لقوات الدعم السريع في محيط
العاصمه
كمعسكرات سوبا جنوب الخرطوم ايضا طيبه
التي نتابعها في شمالها
وصالحه التي نتابعها هنا وكرري في ام
درمان كما ضمن عدم تمكن الدعم السريع من
الحفاظ على مقراته التي تحتوي على
احتياطيات لوجستيه في ولايتي النيل الازرق
وايضا النيل الابيض
وبورسودان والقضارف وكادوغلي وايضا كسلان
اما نجاحات قوات الدعم السريع فتتمثل بقطع
التواصل بين
شمال العاصمه وبين جنوبها من خلال سيطرتها
على الجسور وتعطيل حركه المرور
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا الان نعود لضيوفنا في الخرطوم
ينضم الي الان اللواء الدكتور امين
اسماعيل مجدوب الخبير الامني والاستراتيجي
في مركز الدراسات الدوليه اهلا بكم معنا
حضره اللواء الهدنه دخلت حيز التنفيذ يبدو
هناك التزام بهذه الهدنه التي اعلنت اليوم
على عكس هدنه الامس حيث بقيت الاشتباكات
على ما كانت عليه اذا اردنا ان نتحدث الان
عن هذه الاشتباكات وعن سيطره الجيش
السوداني على مناطق معينه وسيطره الدعم
السريع على المناطق الاخرى كيف يمكن ان
نصف هذه الاشتباكات الحاصله الان
في محاوله انه موجود
عذرا يتقطع صوتك اذا كان في امكانيه ان
تكون في مكان الصوت يكون في اوضح
اسمعك دكتور تفضل
سريع من بعض المواقع مثل
الرئاسي
والمناطق المحيطه بوزاره الماليه في وسط
الخرطوم عموما
للقوات
الافتراضيه
ولكن واضح انه برضو
الوصول الى القياده العامه كرمز وليست
موقع يمكن ان يفيدها بشيء
وبالتالي نشاهد
في طرق
تجاوزات
محاوله الدخول الى الاحياء
تقليديه
زي فقدان الغياب والسيطره
ودي مرحله قبل الاخير
لماذا استهداف المناطق السكنيه يعني هل
هناك من تواجد عسكري مثلا للجيش او للدعم
السريع بين الناس بين الابنيه لانه حسب ما
نتابع منذ خمسه ايام هناك استهداف لمناطق
سكنيه يعني ومعظم من المدنيين
قوات الدعم السريع ساحاول تحديد الموارد
الدوريه والدرعات
بالتالي
تعلم ان القوات المسلحه للمحافظه على
المواطنين لا تستقبل
غير واضح ساعود اليك ريثما يكون الصوت
اوضح دعونا نذهب الى زميلنا سالم ليطلعنا
ايضا على الاوضاع في الخرطوم سالم كنا منذ
قليل نتحدث بانه يبدو هذه الهدنه فيها
القليل من الالتزام ولكن سمعنا بعض
الاصوات لاطلاق النيران وايضا بايره ثقيله
هل ما هو الوضع الان لديك
سالم هل تسمعني
اذ يبدو سالم لا يسمعني وانما الان انضمت
الينا من لندن دكتوره رانيا السائق عضو
منظمه الاطباء السودان من اجل حقوق
الانسان قبل ان اذهب اليها نستمع الى صوت
الطبيعي للاشتباكات في الخرطه
اذا مشاهدينا من حين لاخر نستمع الى
اشتباكات تعود وتتجدد في بعض المناطق في
الخرطوم كان ضيفنا منذ قليل تحدث عن انه
هذه الاشتباكات يبدو بانها تتركز في
البحرين
الخرطوم
والان ما زلنا نستمع الى اطلاق نيران
وايضا الى استخدام اسلحه ثقيله الان اذهب
الى ضيفتنا دكتوره رانيا الصايغ الدكتوره
رانيا هل يمكن ان تطلعين على الوضع ماذا
يصلكم من اخبار حول وضع المستشفيات ووضع
المرضى والكادر الطبي في السودان
شكرا جزيلا لكم على الاستضافه الوضع الصحي
في السودان وضع كارثي تماما يعني النظام
الصحي في السودان انهار تماما ومصيبه
بالشلل التام عدد كبير من المستشفيات خرجت
من الخدمه تماما يقدر عددها
كبيره خاصه مستشفيات العاصمه والخرطوم
خرجت عن الخدمه تماما تم احتلالها من قبل
بعض القوات المسلحه ايضا يعني تم محاصرتها
هناك بعض المرضى في العنايه المشدده ببعض
المستشفيات لا يمكننا حتى نقلهم الى
مستشفيات اخرى يصعب جدا يعني التواصل مع
سيارات الاسعاف وحركه سيارات الاسعاف صعبه
جدا وسط النيران هناك نقص شديد في المعدات
الطبيه المعينات الطبيه الادويه حتى
انابيب الاكسجين يعني نفذت
انقطاع الكهرباء والمياه
نقص حاد في الدواء
حركه المواطنين وهذا النقص دكتوره رانيا
مرده يعني بان مصادر هذه الادويه وهذه
المعدات الطبيه لا تستطيع الوصول الى
المستشفيات ام هي لا تمتلكها اصلا
الاثنين حقيقه يعني اصلا الوضع الصحي كان
في يعني وضع المستشفيات والوضع الصحي في
السودان كانت سيء جدا
ويعني ولا يحتمل يعني الدخول في حاله حرب
وصعوبه الحركه وصعوبه نقل المواد الطبيه
والادويه
فالاثنين يعني اجتمعوا مع بعض بسببانوا مع
بعض لان الوضع الصحي كان اصلا منهار فالان
يعني للاسف يعني اصيب بالدمار الشامل يعني
الوضع الصحي
الان الحاصل الان انه يعني في في بعض
المرضى محاصرين في بعض المستشفيات وكذلك
الاطباء يعني محبوسين من يوم السبت الماضي
في بعض المستشفيات لا يستطيعون الخروج
ويعني انتهى منهم
الامداد وحتى الغذائي يعني في بعض المرضى
حتى ما تناولوا الغذاء لايام يعني
الدكتوره رانيا هل من جهود تقوم بها مثلا
منظمه اطباء السودان او حتى نقابه الاطباء
في السودان او نقابه المستشفيات بالتواصل
مع الاطراف المتنازعه حتى يؤمنوا ممرات
امنه لايصال المعدات الطبيه والادويه
وايضا لتسهيل حركه الكادر الطبي للوصول
الى المستشفيات
نعم الجهود يعني على على قدم وساق التواصل
مع كل الجهات المسؤوله الهلال الاحمر
والطليب الاحمر والمنظمات الدوليه
والانسانيه العامله في السودان وداخل
وخارج السودان
للتواصل مع الاطراف المتنازعه لايقاف هذه
الحرب فورا وايقافه اطلاق النار وتوفير
ممرات امنه لسيارات الاسعاف وللكوادر
الطبيه وللمدنيين من الوصول الى
المستشفيات كل هذه المسائل للاسف لم تنجح
حتى الان ولكن يعني نتمنى ان هذه الهدنه
الجديده
ان تنجح يعني ويتم توفير وتامين ممرات
امنه للكوادر الصحيه وللمواطنين للوصول
الى المستشفيات واخلاء المستشفيات من
المظاهر العسكريه يعني هذه هذه يعني تعتبر
جريمه
الاحتلال المستشفيات من قبل عناصر مسلحه
هي جريمه من جرائم الحرب
يجب ان يتم اخلاء المستشفيات من اي مظاهر
عسكريه والسماح للاطباء بالعمل اداء عمله
والسماح للمرضى بالوصول الى المستشفيات
على كل حال دكتوره رانيا انا اشكرك دكتوره
رانيا الصادق عضو منظمه اطباء السودان من
اجل حقوق الانسان على المشاركه معنا ساذهب
الان الى زميلنا سالم الهاشمي ليطلعنا على
الوضع في الخرطوم سالم اهلا بك معنا
الهدنه افضل من قبل هذا اكيد ولكن اصوات
الاسلحه الذخيره ما زلنا نستمع اليها
وخاصه في بحر الخرطوم هل يمكن ان تطلعنا
على الاجواء الان
ولماذا في البحر الخرطوم ما زالت هذه
النيران نسمع اصواتها
نعم لا تزال ايضا هذه الاصوات مستمره حتى
قبل قليل اصوات الرصاص في منطقه
بالخرطوم وهذه الاصوات هي في كارفور
مربعات سته هذه المنطقه التي تحتوي على
واحد من المعسكرات قوات الدعم السريع هذا
المعسكر الذي كان يتبع لهيئه العمليات
سابقا اصبح معسكر يتباع هذا الدعم السليم
وهي متمركزه فيه وظلت تخرج منه الكثير من
العايره الناريه والمدافع الثقيله
والخفيفه بالاضافه الى مضادات الطائرات من
هذا المعسكر بالضبط بعد ساعات الاتقان
بقليل انطلقت منه واعيره ناريه وكذلك
مضادات الطائرات لكن الان زادت وتيره
هذه الطلقات هنا في كالسي مربع سته ولم
تتوقف الا قبل قليل
اما بالنسبه للخرطوم بحري كان معنا ضيفنا
السيد طاهر قال لنا واكد لنا بانه هذه
الاصوات التي نسمعها عبر كاميرا العربيه
المثبته ايضا في الخرطوم قال لنا بانها في
منطقه الخرطوم بحري هل الخرطوم بحري ايضا
هي المنطقه التي يتواجد فيها قوات الدعم
السريع والسيد حماتي كما يقال
لا اعلم حقيقه عن مكان تواجد لكن المؤكد
ان هذه الاصوات تصدر من
معسكري يتبع لقوات الدعم السريع وايضا
تصدر ايضا من بجوار كوبري شامباستا اقصى
غرب مدينه بحري هذه المنطقه التي تحتوي
ايضا على معسكر المظلات وهو ايضا مؤسسه
كان يتبع لقوات الدعم السريع
تحت امرك الجيش المظلات
المظلات
على الجيش السوداني انه يسيطر عليها لكن
حركه قوات الدعم السليم في هذا الشارع
المؤدي الى الى الجسم جسر شنبات كذلك
حركتها في حله حمد وايضا في الشوارع شارع
المرغنيه كذلك كل هذه الشوارع نجد فيها
حركه تكاد تكون طبيعيه
لقوات تتبع للدعم السريع الدعم السريع بل
ان تعمل سريعه اليوم كانت في ارتكاز في
المؤسسه المؤسسه لا تبعد من المظلات كان
هناك ارتكاز لقوات الدعم السريع كانت توقف
العربات وتسال المواطنين عن مكان حركتهم
هذا بعد صلاه العشاء تقريبا
بالنسبه
للحركه في الخرطوم هل يمكن اعتبارها بانها
مشلوله بالكامل
من كل تاكيد ما دامت الجسور مغلقه لابد ان
تكون الحركه مشغوله يضاف اليها انها اصبحت
في مساحات اكثر ضيقا من قبل ونتحدث عن
المناطق التي تشهد هذه الاصوات اصوات
الاعياد الناريه وكذلك
انطلاق ايضا المضادات الطائرات في هذه
المناطق قله الحركه كثيرا لانها اصبح هناك
ايضا حركه لهذه القوات في الشوارع وهذا
يثير قلقا عند المواطنين
صوت اطلاق النيران والايره الثقيله
والاسلحه الذخيره لا يتوقف خلالها خمس
دقائق التي اتحدث فيها معك دعنا نستمع الى
الصوت الطبيعي ومن ثم اعود اليك
[موسيقى]
اذا استمعنا الى اصوات النيران واصوات
الاسلحه المستخدمه في هذه اللحظات في
الخرطوم حيث من
الهدنه دخلت حيز التنفيذ تقريبا منذ اربع
ساعات في بدايه هذه الهدنه كان هناك يبدو
التزام فيها ولكن الان تشتد هذه
الاشتباكات ونسمع اصوات اطلاق النيران
واستخدام للاسلحه الثقيله اذا هناك عوده
لهذه الاشتباكات بشكل متقطع وهذه
الاشتباكات في محيط القياده العسكريه في
الخرطوم حيث نتابع هذه الصوره الخاصه
بالعربيه مباشره من المنطقه المحيطه
بالقياده العسكريه في الخرطومه سالم اعود
اليك بالامس كنا نتحدث وقلت لي بانه مشهد
الطوابير امام الافران من اجل الخ ايضا
هناك شح في الوقود هل هذا الامر ما زال
مستمرا ام هناك جهود لتامين مثل هذه
الاحتياجات خلال اليوم
نزلت هذه الازمه لمكانها فيما يتعلق
بالامداد الغذائي صفوف القدس وغيرها يضاف
اليها كذلك الذعر وعدم الامانه الذي يشعر
به المواطنين في اماكن هذه النزاعات
هذه الهدنه التي كلما تفائل المواطنون
بوقت مريح فيها
وليس طويلا كذلك تاتي وتعود باخبار اخرى
بان هذه الهدنه بدات في كانها لم تقل ايضا
كان هنالك بيان من اللجنه سفراء الرباعيه
الذين يدعون الى وقت القتال والعوده
للحوار قالون على الالتزام بحمايه
المدنيين والدبلوماسيين وعاملين ولابد من
توفير ممرات امنه العمليات الانسانيه وحتى
سفراء دول الرباعيه للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه والامارات العربيه المتحده
والمملكه المتحده والولايات المتحده هل هو
اطراف الاذاعه
بعد غروب الشمس تتناول هذه الاسره
السودانيه الفاتوره في لحظه صمت تنقطع فيه
اصوات المدافع ويرتفع صوت الاذان في
استراحه قصيره من الاشتباكات بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع
الضائقه الاقتصاديه التي يعيشها السودان
منذ سنوات يسعى المواطنون لتجاهلها ولو
مؤقتا على معده الافطار حيث باتت واقعا
يؤرقهم لا يمكنهم توقع تبعاته في ظل
القتال المحتدم
وبالرغم من انهم ربما تجاهلوا بشكل مؤقت
مشاكلهم الاقتصاديه الا نسمات الغذاء التي
تلوح في الافق اصبحت حقيقه واقعه في
السودان استمرار القتال تسبب في تفاقم
الوضع الانساني المتازم بالفعل 15 مليون
شخص بالكاد تتوفر لديهم مستلزمات الغذاء
الاساسيه بحسب تقرير للامم المتحده تقارير
اخرى تشير الى ان نحو اربعه ملايين طفل
دون الخامسه يعانون من بوادر سوء التغذيه
المعارك الدائره حاليا
مباشره في البنيه التحتيه عائلات بالكامل
استبدلت المشروبات الرمضانيه بالمياه
بعدما استهدفت محطات المياه في بعض
الاحياء مثل بحر شمالي الخرطوم عائلات
اخرى لجات الى الاكتفاء بوجبه واحده فقط
في اليوم في سبيل التعايش مع الظروف
الصعبه
الاحياء الاوفر حظا يقتنص سكانها فرصه
هدوء الاشتباكات ليهرعوا الى محلات
البقاله ليجدوا ارففها فارغه تماما خاصه
التي تحتوي على المياه المعدنيه
اغلب الاحتياجات بنقدر نجيبه بالنسبه
لاغلاق الطعم لسوبر ماركت والدكاكين
السيناريو الاكثر سوءا الذي لم يتوقعه
السودانيون كان اعلان برنامج الغذاء
العالمي وقف مساعداته للبلاد على وقع مقتل
ثلاثه من موظفي نتيجه الاشتباكات بين قوات
الدعم السريع والجيش
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات